foreign
[Music]
happy Thursday everybody and welcome
back to the data science Hangout
and let's see if we remember how to do
this today we were on a little bit of a
break for July I'm so so excited to see
everybody back here hope everyone's
having a great week
if this is your first time joining us
today I know this is a pretty big group
here today so it's so nice to meet you
thank you for spending your Thursday
with all of us if we haven't met yet I'm
Rachel Dempsey I lead our Pro Community
here at posit
and the data science hangout is our open
space to chat about data Science
Leadership questions you're facing and
getting to hear about what's going on in
the world of data across different
Industries
and so every Thursday we feature a
different data leader from the community
and together we're all dedicated to
making this a welcoming environment for
everybody so we love hearing from
everyone in this environment no matter
your level of experience or area of work
this is the casual conversation with us
all here so it's totally okay to just
listen in to but there's always three
ways that you could jump in and ask
questions or provide your own
perspective too
so you can jump in by raising your hand
on Zoom
you can put questions in the zoom chat
and feel free to always put a little
star next to it if you wanted me to read
it instead maybe you're in a coffee shop
or something or I could call on you to
to ask your question and introduce
yourself
and then lastly we also have a slido
link where you can ask questions
anonymously
and Hannah or someone from the team will
share that in the chat hope you already
did thank you
well I am so excited to be joined by my
co-host today for the data science
hangout Hadley Wickham Hadley is Chief
scientist at posit and builds tools to
make data science easier faster and more
fun you might know Hadley's work for
packages like tidyiverse
including Gigi plot 2 and D plier much
more but hardly I'd love to have you
introduce yourself if you tell us
something you like to do outside of work
too and a little bit about what it means
to be Chief scientist here at posit
sure thing thanks for
um thanks for having me Rachel for uh
finally inviting me I'm starting to get
a little hurtful but uh glad I could
finally make it thanks for joining
uh I like outside of work I'd say the uh
I'll give you his have a dog that's Lola
is a 13 year old shar pei and that's
pretty much what she does these days is
sleep
uh I write books
none
this is one of my this is one of my
books that I wrote recently uh to the
cocktail book because I'm also really
into cocktails uh This was
um
because on me all the data for the
cocktails is stored in a yaml file and
then it uses quarto to uh turn into book
and I'll show you
so it has like a table of contents like
the primary organization of the book is
by spirit
but uh because I'm extra
it also has one index that lists all of
the primary ingredients in the Cocktails
so if you want to find like something to
use orange liqueur and then finally
it has an index by name so if you
remember the name of the cocktail I
don't want to find it
um so these are like fixing the things
that like annoy me about cocktail books
that you can never find the cocktail
that you're looking for because they're
ordered in some like arbitrary depending
on the indexes are so bad so thanks to
the the power of courtier quarter and uh
latex and make index it was really easy
to make a super highly indexed book a
few Oscars I have to ask you what's your
favorite from that book
uh actually that's the favorite cocktail
I am enjoying them cocktails I'm
enjoying the most at the moment I'm not
actually in that book because I've only
discovered them uh recently and I can't
even remember what it's called but it
uses
um
it's rum it's an equal parts cocktail
there's rum fire aperol yellow
chartreuse and lime juice and rum fire
is this kind of like a crazy overproof
uh Jamaican one sounds great I see
there's a lot of uh fans here in the
chat
but um but Hadley would love to have you
share with everybody here what does it
actually mean to be Chief scientist at
posit what it what do you do on a daily
basis
good question
um
so like you know these days I manage a
team a tinyverse team who's responsible
for kind of not only the Tidy verse
packages but also many of the packages
and the package development ecosystems
so test that and Dev tools use this and
roxygen and then also some kind of lower
level packages that underpin these
things which often live in the Isle of
GitHub organization
but like management is not my passion I
would say I'm like I do okay uh but it's
not like what I really enjoy and it's
not where I want to spend my time so I
try and still spend as much time as I
possibly can like writing both code and
books
um so I recently kind of realized I just
felt like I felt like I hadn't
been like getting that much done and
I think it was it felt like I just sort
of recognized like that felt like I was
probably mostly in my head but then I
realized the key reason I felt that way
is that it wasn't working on a book
project
so like my when I am working on a book
like I always get up and that's the
first thing I do for the first hour or
two in the morning uh I haven't now I've
seem to be like addicted to writing
books so that when I'm not writing a
book I feel weird and uncomfortable uh
so now that I've started work on the
next book which is going to be called
something like tidy design principles uh
things are feeling much better
so yeah so I do some management I like
writing books and then obviously like
writing uh code uh and recently uh the
packages I've been working on are not
tidy those packages but I've just been
kind of diving in around positive
various open source packages and kind of
sitting where I can pitch in and help
out so about a year ago I guess a long
ago helped out on the pins package and
then more recently I've been working on
the IRS connect package which helps you
deploy your apps to connect and the RNs
package which helps you create reproduce
the whole environments for your code
um so if anybody ever feels like you're
not doing enough write a book right
and I will say like my I will say like
my advice for writing a book is that
it's easy you just have to write for an
hour it's simple I should say you did
the right for an hour every day every
year and the end of it of a book uh and
as far as I know no one has ever
successfully followed that advice
not very good advice
so we have a really big crew here today
so I'm going to repeat how people can
like ask questions and jump into because
I know a few people join after and it's
so nice to see you all here if this is
your first time joining so nice to meet
you and this is an informal casual
conversation with us all here so you can
ask questions and
chat with us in a variety of ways so you
could raise your hand on zoom and I'll
be able to see that you can put
questions in the zoom chat and then
Hannah will share a slider link again
here where you can ask questions
anonymously too just want to make sure I
said that in case somebody joined after
I I put it there
um
but I see Mike Smith you had a question
in the chat do you want to jump in here
first
yeah thanks um so this is I I don't know
if if you can answer it directly hardly
but if you can kind of give us a feel
for it so the Tidy verse is huge it's a
massive number of packages massive
number of developers how does posit kind
of hurt the cats and making sure that
all of these different development
Pieces come together and work together
effectively
yeah I would I'd say most of that is
just like we talk a lot amongst the team
and we talk pretty frequently about
uh like what you know like what when
we're designing apis like why do we
favor this design over that design like
if we've got something that's that's you
know important or complex like that
that's something we'll talk over in a
team meeting and that is like having
multiple people think about these
problems I think is just the key because
it's too it really is past the point
anyone per person can keep it all on
their heads and it's very easy to
accidentally introduce inconsistencies
because you've forgotten help some
function you wrote 10 years ago works
so it's like just like that a lot of you
know we're a pretty close-knit team that
works closely together that's really
important uh the other thing
uh which I'm working on which I can pop
a link to in the chat is this book
called
um
tidy design principles
which is where like now I'm trying to
write up some of these principles which
is like useful you know it's useful for
us because of encode you know codes them
in writing and we can look them up but
it was also helpful hopefully useful for
the community so you can both like see
the patterns we follow and get a more of
a glimpse into kind of like how we think
about these things so the goal is to
have both kind of these are things you
should do but also like like this is
what we were thinking when we designed
this interface like these the thing like
these are the trade-offs we considered
these are all of the options we consider
this is why we rejected this one for
this one and then you know looking back
now like did we regret those choices
like when we've made different choices
if we knew then what we knew
you now
I was waiting to see if you had a
follow-up there Mike I saw your nodding
I see Talking is definitely you know the
A1 tip
but it I can imagine it you know from a
project management perspective it must
be difficult to to ensure that all of
these things just you know because
they're like Lego pieces you want them
to just clip together right
yeah yeah and definitely something we
spent a lot of time thinking about
so I see quite a few questions starting
to come in now here Andy I see you asked
a question in the chat about some of the
books do you want to jump in here
yes thanks uh just Hadley I saw you I
think post on LinkedIn the other day or
somewhere about the upcoming book is
there a is there a difference between
the design principles and say like the r
cookbook or our recipes or is that is it
kind of an extension of those
yeah so I I don't know I've written a
lot of books about that now uh but I
would say like you know I think of like
Opera data science is like if you're you
know if you want to learn how to do data
science and uh
Advanced odds if you want to learn how
art works as a programming language and
there's kind of this Gap in between them
like how do you go from you know someone
being a just a you know a data scientist
who's analyzing uh like individual data
sets to someone who's starting to design
like kind of bigger pieces of code like
functions that you can use in multiple
analyzes or maybe eventually you collect
enough of those functions you want to do
a package
so like how do you like when you're
writing a function like what do you
think about like how do you like how do
you pick the arguments how do you name
the arguments how do you choose how they
should interact
so hopefully I think this is not you
know this is a book that's you know
you've got to be fairly far along in
your your journey with r and data
science because now you're wanting to
write bigger functions but I think this
is a pretty this is sort of a gap in the
current
selection of our books which compared to
other programming languages just to have
far fewer books on kind of like you know
General programming topics like like
design
thank you
okay I'm gonna ask a question over from
slido
um and as a reminder you can ask
questions anonymously there too but one
was have you learned anything
particularly noteworthy about the python
community
uh and or space since posits rebranding
uh
uh yes
I I don't know like I don't know how to
put this or that
saving me but I just feels like the
python data stinks but it's just like so
hard to do data science
right then it's like so many things that
are like annoying from like the
environment management problems they're
doing things that I feel like they
should be simple in pandas to like you
know I don't know just it feels like I'm
a sort of continue to be amazed at
people I was productive as they are in
Python what they have there with the
tools they have on hand and so I think
one of the things I'm kind of excited
about is like posit you know starts to
contribute to this space is how can we
kind of bring our magic of like it just
works into this space so that people can
just like do data science and python
without without having to worry about
all of these kind of extraneous things
that aren't that interesting to data
scientists
thank you
um Smita I see you had asked the
question in the chat do you want to jump
in here
yeah so this question for Henley when
you design packages how do you factor in
security given the increasing number of
hacking and other attacks that are
happening in the Enterprise space these
days thank you
okay
yeah I would security is a difficult a
difficult one because I think in most
like most of the Tidy verse it just
doesn't like really apply like you know
you don't have to worry about security
and Gigi pot too for example
um like we we think about it more in the
packages that have to require
authentication
um so typically you know when you're
getting data whether it's from an API or
a database you're going to need to store
those credentials somehow and one of the
things I've been thinking about in
particular recently as I've been working
more on like you know using our pro
products is like you how do you make
sure those credentials travel kind of
both seamlessly and securely from
wherever you're doing the analysis to
wherever you're deploying the analysis
So currently I think we're at the stage
there's a lot around like how do we help
our users learn the right conventions
like you should never be typing your
password and into the console because if
you do that uh it's easy for it to end
up save in your history file and it's
easy to accidentally come at that to get
and now you've shared your password a
much wider range of people than you
should be
so at the moment there's I think a lot
of use of environment variables which
are a little bit safer uh at least
because you're not storing them
literally in in your code but how can we
do better at you know providing tools
for six percent
for saving those securely and then we're
needed like sharing them across from
your computer to connect or the shiny
apps or whatever
so I think lots of questions there not a
lot of answers currently
Sanjay I see you had a question in the
chat earlier too do you want to jump in
here
yeah I had one thing which always
intrigued me is our company always
looked at purchasing the Post-it R
Studio connect or posted connect but we
never got a proper sales pitch and could
you articulate what advantages uh posted
our studio connect has over the open
source version please
yeah so I would say like the
the reason why you want connect or it's
kind of like main value proposition to
me is it helps get your data analyzes
out of the hands of data scientists into
the hands of decision makers
and at the end of the day like it
doesn't matter how awesome you are the
data scientists unless you can show your
results to people your analyzes people
in your organization who actually need
them
and so connect is really about like
publishing whatever you're doing in our
uh to a to a form that other people in
your organization could see whether it's
like shiny apps or armac or quarter
documents or if you want to turn those
into like a scheduled report so that
people are getting emailed at 9am every
day with latest results in your
dashboard it's all about like sharing
what you're doing as a data scientist
and and ideally like the goal of connect
which we're not like 100 of the way
there but we're trying to get there uh
in the long run very much the goal is
we've got to do that just by like
pushing a button in your R Studio
wherever you're doing the analysis it
should just be a single click or a
single function call to keep that up so
you can stay focused on the you know the
data analysis rather than having to
worry about like running a web server
securing a web server making all the
auto authentication is working make sure
your emails jobs are getting sent out
correctly and when those jobs fail all
that you get notified that they didn't
work and all that kind of other stuff
which is like really necessary for a
product workers to work but probably you
don't care about as a data scientist and
thinking about it just gets in the way
of doing your doing your most important
work well but quite a lot of it is
achieved from our student our studio
open source server also isn't it all
right like tip yes like you could be
doing analysis and open source products
but there's no open source tool that's
quite the same as connect you can
certainly string it together with a
bunch of different Open Source Products
but I think our belief would be it's
gonna cost you much less time in this
much less money to just buy this thing
that we have built where the cost of
building it is amortized over you know
thousands of customers rather than you
having to pay their cost Yourself by
developing that open source solutions
from scratch
got it thank you
awesome thank you thank you for all
these great questions coming in
um Livy I see you just asked one that is
getting so many hearts and reactions
right now so I'm going to have you jump
in here and ask that
sure I'm always swooping in with the
touchy-feely questions
um
when JJ was on he gave you a lot of
credit for the culture at our studio now
pause it and so I was kind of wondering
if there was anything that you did any
steps that you took to kind of make sure
that
our studio moved that direction or kind
of could embody the stuff that you hoped
culture wise
I'm laughing just because I think that's
like classic JJ because I think he's way
more responsible for the culture than I
am
um
but
you know I will say I think the thing
that
that both JJ and I share is that I think
like while we are both like really good
programmers that we don't believe that
makes us like better human beings in any
way just a skill that we happen to have
and that I think you know as people with
with these skills it's our
responsibility to help the people that
we can help with them
um and it's it's just been so wonderful
working with JJ and Tarif and the whole
leadership team at positive over the
last 10 years because I think that those
values are really
strongly instilled now and now now
company culture that like we try and do
the right things you know we're a b Corp
because we don't want to optimize for
you know short-term profits
we want to be in this for the long term
we want to be able to make the like the
right decisions
that help us out in the community out in
the long term not just do what's exigent
in the in the moment
thank you okay jumping over to one on
slido is what gaps do you see in the our
ecosystem for example most deep learning
and AI applications are built with pi
torch tensorflow and Keras do you see R
catching up
yeah I I don't see our catching up there
I think the the python is just such a
huge Community there
um that are is never going to catch up
and that's fine like ah it doesn't have
to be good at everything ours I was not
python uh I can be good at like a you
know a set of really important tasks it
doesn't have to embrace it
and they can do that because you know
our as fundamentally the sort of glue
language that there's no sense amongst
our users that are must be the only
language you use you you know you use it
as much as it helps you and then you use
the tools like reticulate to talk to
python or while the you know the
building stuff we're talking to C and C
plus plus and new stuff for Tonga rust
and go that you know you talk to the
whatever systems your data lives in from
R and then you benefit from this
environment that I believe is just
unparalleled or fluid interactive data
exploration
Jesse I see you had a question in the
chat a bit earlier do you want to jump
in here
and at some point because we have so
many I might need to say first and last
names
but it's Jesse Osman I can ask I can ask
the question if you want to add any
context feel free
um but the question was when writing
books using Cordo are there any helper
packages that you would use to help
format those files to actually look like
books and how do you get those quarter
files print ready yeah that's a great
question and the answer depends a lot on
kind of exactly what your target is for
the book and kind of where your skills
lie so like for the cocktails book
that's
self-published hopefully obviously
there's no I'm not signing up with
cocktail book uh Publishers and I did
that that a lot of that is kind of
custom like it uses Corto but at a lot
of customization
um what latex uh using my limited latex
skills and much Googling and some GPT to
get things working
um
but other stuff like the like if you're
publishing with O'Reilly now quarto can
output to ASCII dark which is what
O'Reilly uses other Publishers like more
scientific Publishers you will need to
create a PDF typically using latex and
then you'll need to do some
customization yourself I think like that
that tool chain from lab tech to PDF is
kind of still
[Music]
um
the the best formed route uh obviously
it requires some understanding of latex
uh I will say that is
both like impossible to gain any
meaningful understanding of latex
without probably Decades of work but
fortunately like Googling and copying
and pasting and some fair amount of
prostration will typically find what you
want because pretty much everything you
want someone's already done and it's
just a matter of like finding the right
snippet to paste it and hope it doesn't
conflict with the other stuff
uh I I think like
like lighting is definitely in the past
I think we're seeing kind of more tools
like page down uh where you could render
like you know PDF kind of quality
outputs using HTML engines
uh that you know I think solved one set
of problems and introduces another now
you've got to learn some like CSS for
customization uh but I think we'll see
more and more of that in the future
I also just don't really think about
like I still think like the primary
version of my books is the online
version I think that is what most people
um read and I just think about the
physical books it's kind of like a nice
offshoot that I don't I honestly don't
really care about because
I did not read physical books anymore so
I know so I know some people do it it's
nice to have them but it's just the
online version I think is so much more
important I love all this conversation
happening in the chat right now too and
just want to say if you're joining us
for the first time that's where a lot of
people end up meeting each other too and
like sharing helpful links with each
other too so feel free to jump in there
and thank you to the posit folks in the
back end who are helping me pull out
some of the questions from there
um Alan I see you had asked oh sorry you
go ahead can I pull one out yeah so
someone ask you about these
which actually uh embroidery
takes logos
galpan so I have a lot of uh
things like that that you might see my
uh
like a crochet distribution
Halloween
thinking back to the the hex dress that
I saw at the r Studio conference
sometimes all the amazing things people
make with the hexes
I think the most impressive oppressive
con-related
um thing I saw was like someone had like
tidy verse exes or painted on their
nails
that they've done themselves but that
was really really impressive to do it
that small
absolutely
um Alan I see you had a question here in
the chat do you want to jump in
I do I really I put in a couple Rachel
where you I've all in a specific one
um you could ask your favorite one but I
see that um people were coming or
uploading your B core question I'll go
with the most recent one yeah the B Corp
one I'm I'm curious heavily if as a in
the B Corp landscape are there like are
there Piers that look like posit or
doing similar things or are you alone
and like what's that like to either have
some sort of well-trib ground to follow
or is it figuring out like every day
like strategically what is positive as a
B chord do in this kind of situation and
it is and I'm sort of curious curious if
that's like liberating or if it's
terrifying
um like like what's that like kind of to
think about operationally being in that
space I'd say we
do some benchmarking against other B
Corps in the places where benchmarks are
typically available like I know we do is
like our employee kind of satisfaction
survey as we pinch that to Benchmark
those against other B Corps
but I don't I don't
I mean I don't really know if there are
B Corps like us I suspect they're not
they're just not that many like software
pre-corps that are not that many open
source companies
and
I guess that I don't know that feels
kind of like more freeing to me than
worrying
um you know certainly unless a lot of
what we do is just a standard you know
there's a lot of there's just kind of
standard software business Playbook
um but at the same time we don't have
this like more about removing this drive
to optimize short-term profitability
that gives us the room to kind of
um you know do the things that we
believe to be right you know as much as
possible it's not always possible to you
know it's it's like like what is right
is a very complicated question
especially of the size of a company
grows but certainly we you know we we
have the more freedom to kind of think
about that and act on that and while you
know certainly we still make mistakes I
think everyone is you know trying trying
to absolute best thanks appreciate that
and whereas I see you ask the question
here in the chat you want to jump in
next
oh sure I'll hop on real quick uh and
good effort on the last name
um oh sorry yeah can you tell me how to
say it it's like Ferris just okay uh so
you've taken a lot of solutions to
massive pain points that are challenging
and non-obvious
um
I know if I try to do something like
ggplot I would make no progress
whatsoever so I wonder
how do you find your starting points for
implementation like where do you start
from and how do you measure your
progress and make sure you're moving
towards your end goal good question uh
it feels like a lot of
the packages that I work on just have
this
this sense of inevitability about them
but these are just things that like
frustrate me and typically have
frustrated me for years before like some
kind of solution crystallizes in my head
and then it's just a matter of like
a lot of iteration and you know now I
think one of the huge advantages I have
is that you know there's a people
there's a community of people who are
willing to try out like whatever crap I
produce and give me like feedback and
tell me like you know this doesn't work
or this I don't understand this or this
is inconsistent with a lot of our tidy
and that is just I find that that kind
of a direction like personally like you
know highly motivated that people care
when people care enough
to
like critique it I find that to be yeah
really motivating so I think that that
it's just that
I don't know some weird part of my brain
that is just like collecting these
little pain points and after a while
kind of realizing that all of these pain
points like maybe there's some root
cause that they can fix all at once uh
other times it's like let's just rough
you know knock them off one by one and
then hope something falls out
yeah and it's just this they still feel
like a lot of packages it just feels
like I feel like there's a sort of
compulsion to create them but
occurs inside of him at some points in
my life all right so it feels like
you're a force of nature though yeah
a slido question somebody had asked was
do you have any recommendations for
teaching not
coder data generators that it's good to
use tidy structured data so we can use
their data so much more easily
yeah I think the
like the challenge of teaching anything
like this is always you you have to
figure out what are the benefits to them
not what are the benefits to you because
the benefits to you are typically very
obvious but are not motivating to other
people so you you need to figure out
like what's some angle where by adopting
these new ideas can they save themselves
work or can they produce something cool
and and maybe that's like if it's not
about saving if you can't find any way
that it's going to save them work maybe
there's something you can do with the
title beta automatically to produce some
kind of useful plot or motivating figure
that will kind of help them say like oh
this is you know this is kind of fun so
I think yeah like try and make it easier
or try and make it more fun uh anything
else like it's it's a hard It's A Hard
Road to get other people to change their
minds and to change their processes
David Mesa I see you asked a question in
the chat you want to jump in here next I
did and I apologize my video is not
working hey Hadley how are you doing hey
good um one of the questions I had two
questions one of them was around tidy
models in vetiver
um they've done a lot of good work on
trying to expand the ml Ops in an
organization
any thoughts or about what may be
happening in the future how do we can
get better ml apps in organizations
using posit yeah that's a good question
I mean I I think our sort of Hope is
like as we get better at integrating our
open source tools and our professional
tools some of that would just kind of
happen
naturally I think that's you know one of
the things we're struggling with or
struggle with as an organization is like
how do we help this like fairly
disparate teams with quite different
cultures like work together and create
solutions that you know work with people
out in the real world
so I I think that that's an appeals to
me like where the missing pieces are
like we want to deliver these like end
to end Solutions which like just work
and if we can you know make model
deployment really easy model deployment
and monitoring really easy for you
hopefully people will use it more thank
you I think a lot of chat about uh hex
tattoos different Paws in our studios in
there from
uh my friend is Harley Quinn Simmons is
in case
and it's kind of hard to see the case of
emergency brake Glass and its brass
knuckles with tidy
um one and data on the other
nice
um let's see so many great questions
here
um trying to trying to get to
everybody's I see Jake you asked Jake
Riley you asked a question here in the
chat oh yeah uh I know that there's
other packages under the Tidy verse like
Luber date was a separate package that
you would have to load instead of Teddy
versus not included I was curious how
you pick which packages come along and
I'm hoping glue is next ah glues not
next because you can already kind of get
to it using Str glue because it's that's
re-imported for
Like Glue is a little bit of a tricky
candidate because it was kind of
designed to be
well maybe
yeah I think glue I don't know glue just
feels like too small
to be like at this level especially when
you can get to like 95 percent of the
functionality via Str underscore glue
um
so generally yeah I think like the
tidiness now is pro like I don't see any
much likelihood that the membership is
going to change and the next couple of
years just because Libra day that
there's been a goal to get lubricated
this but
you know like something like five years
now and finally kind of all the like
various bits that we had to deprecate
and fix in various places kind of
thought mature enough we could pull it
pull the trigger on that but so for
something else to be out of the Tidy
verse like we'd have to be you know
start work now and it would happen in a
couple of years and there's nothing on
the on the table currently Ben asked the
question I think Ben maybe had to drop
for another call but I'm gonna so I'll
ask it but the question was well I'm
bought into developing open source
packages to help deliver better
processes any advice to those of us
doing that development in getting their
company buy-in again it's like how do
you like you've gotta give some benefit
to the people using this
and you've got to like either remove
pain or add pleasure in some way because
if you can't do that and you're not
someone's like direct supervisor with a
lot of direct power over them it's hard
to get people the change so I think like
to me a lot of it's like well the way I
think about the Tidy verse is like how
do we give people
some sort of like quick wins so they can
be motivated to do the stuff that are
like slower with where they're gonna
have to learn more like learn some new
ideas or some new tools
um so that you kind of build up some
kind of equity with that person like
they they brought out some trust that
you've helped them in the past and now
they're willing to invest like a little
bit more time before they see the payoff
but in the early days it's all about
like you know delivering payoffs as
quickly as possible and I think if
you're doing like you know you're like
my company's first star package like
that the easy pain points are like make
themes for your company corporate style
guide like make a Gigi bot 2 theme make
an hour markdown a quarter theme make a
shiny theme that people can just use to
get you know something that's reasonably
close to whatever your corporate style
guide dictates and that's just like a
that just feels like an easy win for
people because it makes both of them
look good inside the corporation and
because you've put in all this hard work
it's like three seconds for them to type
the right function then to get the right
theme
and then I think the other bit is like
make it easier to get access to data
um like so set up some wrappers around
DBI connections to the most important
data sources provide some conventions
around authentication so that stuff just
works so that they're not like you're
not struggling like how do I what
package do I need to install like what's
the password where's the path I need
just give them some like a list of the
top 10 most common data sources and like
people will love you very much
thank you Brittany I see your hands
raised do you want to jump in here next
yeah I actually had a similar question
to Ben and I maybe try to phrase a
little differently so when you are
thinking about sort of developing maybe
that first package for your company or
something of that nature once you've
identified the things that you think
would be useful for people do you have
like a philosophy or a way in which you
approach kind of putting things together
because I know one of the pain points is
as you're developing you realize oh what
I did originally doesn't quite work and
I have to tear it down and kind of build
it back up again so I don't know if you
yeah you have like Lessons Learned From
developing so many packages that we can
learn from
yeah that's
I think it's a tough one because I think
like as a team we have got like vastly
better at dealing with kind of
deprecations and breakages and I was
reminded of this recently because I had
to rebuild the first edition of alpha
data science
and it just works like five years later
all the code in that book still works
which is certainly not like true like
five years ago if you tried to do that
with five years of code in the title
because it wouldn't have worked
um and you know I think that that that's
obviously great to have that but it's
also like a huge amount of extra work to
do that and like we can kind of afford
the spare Network because now we're a
team of like you know at least my team
is like six plus full-time people who
can spend their time thinking about this
um because I think there's really like
when you're in a environment of like
scarcity when you've only got like so
much time that you can take out of your
kind of like everyday job to invest in
writing a package like it's really tough
to balance like how do I like add new
stuff versus making sure the old stuff
continues to work
um so I don't have any great advice
there I I think again some of it's about
coming like building up trust so like
give people some wins so that when you
do inevitably Break Stuff like either
accidentally or on personalists you've
got some like kind of cushion that so
people aren't going to get like really
angry with you right away they're going
to be like oh okay well
you know there's a little bit of
suffering now but this person saved me
so much time
um but it's not so bad
um but yeah it's really hard and
particularly as you're starting out like
you're gonna make mistakes like that's
inevitable and you're gonna do things
that when you look back a year later
you're like why on Earth did I do it
that way
uh and now you want to like rip out the
whole thing and write it from scratch
and I
think that like if it feels horrible but
you have to remember like that's great
because it means you've grown immensely
as a programmer and certainly if you
have like my kind of mindset you have to
like resist the temptation to like rip
things out and redo them as much as
possible and just focus on making the
Next Generation better rather than
Breaking what what stuff people already
have so I I don't have any great answers
yet but I think you've just got to think
about those tensions of like how do I
keep my forward velocity up while
getting better as a programmer while
evolving over time but you know things
and I'm also thinking about how do you
make the things you did a long time ago
better thank you for that thank you I
see there are a few questions that
mention chat GPT
um one was from Ian ianson what is your
opinion on how it will evolve the data
scientists role in an organization I
will caveat my remarks with I
I would say 99 of my jet GPT use is
entirely frivolous
I use it to make things rhyme I use it
to make things sound like Pirates
uh I use it to make things sound like
Southern grandmas who use a lot of
country
folk sayings I use it to make acrostics
of people's names uh I use it now with
uh like the finance person I work with I
submit requests exclusively in the form
of office screenplays
um
so I I don't know I think it's like
incredibly fun for stuff like that when
I have tried to use it for programming
ah it's been like hit or miss like
sometimes it's great
and sometimes it spits out something
that looks like totally plausible but is
utterly wrong so it's and it's hard for
me to tell like is that just like
is that chat GPD today and like in a
year's time it's going to be much better
or is it going to be like self-driving
cars where they're kind of always coming
like a year in the future and we never
quite get there
um self-driving cars is something I
think about a lot because I have a Tesla
and whenever I park in the garage it
thinks the random collection of tools
hanging on the wall is a semi like about
to crash into us and I'm like it can't
even handle like this and people say
we're gonna have self-driving cars
so so I I don't know what time for me to
say I'd say overall I'm kind of like a
skeptic I think it is going to be useful
I think it's particularly probably it's
hard for me to say like in some ways
it's going to be really useful when
you're learning because you can take the
things that are worth in your head and
split them out and say like how do I
rotate the x-axis labels on the GG plot
and get something pretty reasonable
which makes it super useful for learning
but at the same time as you're learning
it's going to spit out stuff that looks
totally plausible but is totally wrong
and you're in the worst possible
situation to try and figure out what's
going on so I I don't know we'll see I
think it's super exciting I have a lot
of fun with it but I do not use it more
professionally yet it seems like there's
a lot of people who think those are
great use cases of it the way you're
using it
um let me go over here recently
um we had a company meeting recently we
had some customers come out and I took
their bios and just made chat GPT make
them rhyme and the people were like so
impressed
so impressed I'm like I just made check
keeping do you make a rhyme
I see there's a lot of conversation
beneath use question you do you want to
jump in here hi oh hi how's it been uh
nice to meet you a big fan of your work
so my question is uh what's the
implementation plan of our own cloud
computing platforms so multimoxing Azure
I and how to it's using art there is
very convenient advice so previously
before we moved towards your the work of
my team I would say 70 or 70 in Python
after moving towards you already quickly
change to 70 in Python 30 in R so python
is just a very natural option for
modeling analysis there so that's
positive how many plan to change this in
the future yeah I mean I don't know if
change is quite the right phrase because
I know if we have the power to do that
but certainly you know what we are
trying to do is make r as easy as
possible to use everywhere you can
possibly use it uh and I you know I
think thinking about like as more and
more people move to cloud computing how
can we make it easy to get set up and
get configured and make things just work
is really important uh I know like one
example at the moment as we're working
on a partnership with with databricks to
make using our inside databricks
clusters much much easier uh certainly
like this seems like there's a lot of
like just challenges getting things set
up there that you know folks have kind
of solved on the python side and no one
has put the time into and saw them on
the outside so I'm hoping that as a
company will continue to invest in in
those opportunities just make it easy to
use for everyone
Lisa I see you had a question earlier on
ggplot2 do you want to jump in sure I
think I asked two questions about gd52
but I think I'll go with the first one
which is
um sort of how do you feel about
uh people contributing
having so many people to contributing to
that package and like all the add-ons
that I've come from out of it
um sort of like any
any things that sort of amazed you and
then on the opposite side any sort of
major frustrations yeah I mean I think
the thing that's kind of kind of blows
my mind about ggplot2 is it's like
coming up so it's going to come up to
its 18th birthday fairly soon so I'm
sort of joking about that will be time
to like emancipate it and it's going to
just have to like Survive by itself from
now on
um
and kind of realistically like I'm not
that involved in the day-to-day
management of GG part 2 anymore that
torch is kind of been passed to
to Thomas Peterson it was now you know
starting to get you know like if I guess
I don't know four years ago I was like
sick of maintaining GG boxer
sick of maintaining a higher Thomas and
now Thomas just kidding sick of
maintaining it so we've got to like
figure out what to do next
um but yeah like maintaining something
that is like so popular
is you know both of blessing and a curse
it's like incredible to know that you
know literally millions of people have
used it and it's helped them you know
made graphs and make their life easier
but it also is like immensely
challenging to make any changes because
like so many people rely on it now and
are used to the the defaults so there's
there's something like I think both
I don't know if I can quickly pull this
off but like one thing I think about a
little
a little bit from time to time it's just
like how many people
like if I find the most
popular yeah so the most popular page on
the GG part 2 website is the Geon bar
documentation
which 15 000 people have read
in the last month
like there are not many ways you can
reach like you can have more of an
impact on people's lives and by looking
at that page about bar charts and
thinking how can we make that theater
um but at the same time those changes
tend to be kind of small and incremental
so it's also like fun to like you know
embark on completely new projects that
no one uses so you're free to do
whatever you want
and in some ways I think like the the
ecosystem of packages is kind of it
takes a combination of those strength
and those weaknesses because like Gigi
pop 2 can like stay the same and stable
whereas you can continue to like build
on top of it with these packages that
fewer people use but are also like much
more easier to change and and flexible
so they definitely have like mixed
feelings about like this like both like
it's all certain like when people use my
stuff and you know they just they feel
so good but it's also like oh now I have
to like answer their questions or they
can't just change things really nearly
so I also do like work on things that no
one uses that's also a different a
different kind of fun sadly something
that's like stood out in my mind that
I've learned from you from an internal
company calls is
how you handle Focus time and the way
you you manage your own time and I
thought it might be helpful just to chat
a little bit about that and to share how
you think about that yeah I uh one sort
of one funny I like it I gave a talk
about this idea of focused time
and a couple of years ago we've been out
of the company and I was like I feel
like the truest expression of My
Philosophy would be to say no I'm not
going to give a talk about Focus time
that's going to interrupt my work for
the day
but I I really try to like create a lot
of time for like uninterrupted work
because I think you know like
programming is like fundamentally
creative work
and like finding the time to kind of
like process and think things through is
is really important
um so what my what I do currently is I
like every day as I said I try and like
first thing I do I get up and write for
a couple of hours or an hour at least
um that's like the time of the day where
I am most productive and so I want to
spend on the things I think are most
important you know not the things that
are necessary most urgent
and then you know I have a team so I
have to I have to talk to them but and I
have to talk to my colleagues that
father of course I love talking to but
it means I can't do other work so my
kind of compromise is I've walked two
days a week off on my calendar Tuesdays
and Thursdays where I try really really
hard not to do these things you know
sometimes if there's like a bigger
meeting that has like 15 people and it's
a possible to find a time otherwise I'll
do it but I really generally pretty good
about keeping those days clear so I can
tackle bigger problems and I think
that's you know really important it's
it's of course challenging because you
have when you've got a big four hour
block of time you still have to like
train yourself to like resist the
Temptations of tick tock and
uh Mastodon or certainly that
temptation of Twitter has been totally
removed from me today these days so I
guess that's
good
um but certainly like you have to train
yourself to land you know hard to like
stay focused on one thing and uh not
given to all the other more fun
distractions that you have around you
but giving yourself that space I think
is really important thank you so much
I know this hour always goes by very
quickly and there's so many great
questions so maybe I can collect those
and share them with you at some point
hardly and you can think about how to
answer them all
um
but another question that I'd love to
ask you is
are there any books you'd recommend to
this audience here or resources you'd
recommend that have been useful for you
in your career yeah let me show you
let's see if I can find
the ones I like the most I just keep
around you know
this is one of the books that's kind of
been inspiring or has inspired the Tidy
verse uh design book it's called a
pattern language it's actually a book
about architecture and how you design
houses
uh it's just a really like you know it's
a very thick book but it's designed to
be kind of skimmable I think it's just a
sort of fun and interesting to read
about and this like system of describing
all of these components of the different
levels of hierarchy and how you can join
them together I think is very much uh
connected to programming
I'll also say like one one reason I
start reading physical books it's like
and I look at these books now and I'm
like oh my God why is the font so small
but
it's because I am
becoming middle aged and becoming
increasingly short-sighted book sex
um
I don't know I think that that's the
book I've been thinking about like the
most
lately some of the other ones I guess
have
gotten rid of
because I had the limited book space and
I kind of like keeping these and also
this collection of like
you know clearly historical books
um
this is like from 1923 because there's
just so much
like when you kind of look
back at what people were doing like 100
years ago
like I think it's really revealing that
in many cases like
the quality of visualizations has not
improved very much like the quality of
the best visualization does not improved
a huge amount in the last hundred years
but the ease of making them like now you
can like whip out 15 variations in GG
applied in 15 minutes whereas before
you're like painstakingly draw them all
out with pandemic so I think it's just
sort of interesting to
reflect on that a little bit and like
what's what's changed really in
visualization in the last 100 years I
know we're at the end here but maybe one
inspirational uh question to ask you
what's something that you're you're most
excited about as you think about
maybe the the Tidy verse and pause it
going forward and I I am like
legitimately really excited about us
embracing python more you know I'm still
not going to be accusing python but I
went to a python conference recently and
talked to a bunch of people using Python
and I'm just excited about helping out
all these python using data scientists
because it just feels like there's this
posit like it just works
type stuff it's just a huge huge scope
for there and I'm you know excited to
kind of help spread that like deposit
way of doing things a positive kind of
community how we think about people and
try and you know spread that you further
further in the world thank you so much
Hadley is that our new slogan it just
works I think it should be well well I
don't know like we're certainly not here
everywhere but I just think that's like
that's what the best experience you can
deliver is you just try something out
and it works and people stop remarking
on that because it just works they have
to think about that and I think that's
and we'll say I think some of the best
packages that me and my team have
created are almost invisible because
they just make problems go away and you
never need to think about them you never
need to know about them because there's
just some pain you never need to
experience and then you can just listen
to all the old uh it's cranking on about
how terrible it was back in the day and
how they had to trudged Barefoot to
school and three feet of snow and just
listen to their stories and be happy you
you don't live in that environment
anymore
thank you so much again for joining us
today Hadley and and thank you all so
much for for joining the hangout today
and and making this space what it is
it's pretty impressive to have over 200
people on a zoom call and not have to
worry about what's happening and thank
you all for monitoring the space too it
if this was your first hangout we would
absolutely love to have you join us
again so again they happen every
Thursday same time same place
um I'll put the link again where you can
just add it to your calendar but next
week we'll be joined by Mike Lopez
senior director of football data and
analytics at the NFL
so he'll be our featured leader next
week and
if you have any questions about it or
wanted
reach out to me feel free to connect on
LinkedIn as well
thank you all so much for joining today
and have a great great rest of the day
great rest of the week bye everybody
thanks Rachel thanks everyone bye